this is a certificate from the Guinness
World Records it's for the largest
functional microprocessor model which
has 40 mm 370 transistors and built by
James Newman in the UK in Cambridge and
this is the mega processor
it's basically a micro processor made
purely from transistors and we're
talking discrete transistors the ones
that you can handle not sort of the ones
that are in the silicon chips we know so
it's a fully functional machine it's
made of these panels as you see around
the room here each panel has its own
specific function within the processor
so the memory is made of all these
little transistors here as the rest is
but each one has an LED on it as well so
the important thing about the mega
processor is every single part of the
machine every single gate has an LED on
its input and output so you can see all
the data everywhere in the machine and
actually how it's working as well the
memory actually kind of then functions a
little bit more as a screen so we have
here a game of Tetris that's playing on
there at the moment we'll show you that
in a minute
so we have the state machine or
computers have a state machine so it
knows what it's doing at any one given
time all of the instruction decoding and
the branch calculations all that kind of
thing I've done on these ones here this
panel is the special purpose registers
arithmetic and logic control the arrow
you again a are you part of all
processors so it has two adders in this
machine I had a one added to there and
then the ALU control down the bottom
general-purpose registers so as you make
a move you would move it to register one
and then out to maybe a special purpose
register or memory depending on what
operations you're doing so all of this
together forms effectively a
microprocessor so we have a number of
LEDs okay and you can see these LEDs are
on but if we focus in on just one little
bit here those five transistors make it
a NAND gate so all of that lot is just
one endgame and we can see on the two
inputs to the end we have one is on one
is off the output is off so for a NAND
gate the logic says both inputs 1 & 2
have to be on ok first the function so
we haven't we've only got one of them on
therefore the output is off and this is
just multiplied up
whole system is using this kind of
functions and Gates or gates and excells
and various then combination of those
you can use the hotel and then gate into
an inverter which some of them are done
down there and it's a microprocessor is
just that what we've got here is a
machine that looks like it's not doing
very much it's kind of fairly static but
we have a special controller here a huge
rheostat or some kind of 40 science film
what they can do is actually running at
about 19 kilohertz of the minute but we
can slow it down
13:10 7 kilohertz and as we slow it down
we start to see the LEDs flickering a
little bit there a little bit of flicker
so now we're at about 100 Hertz and as
we come down further 10 Hertz right and
now we're down at about roughly 2 Hertz
so now we can start to see the
individual instructions being operated
so again it's running tetris at the
moment it's actually in it's game over
state so at first the machine looks like
it wasn't doing anything but when we
start down we see actually it is doing
something and one of our special purpose
registers is the program counter so this
is the part of the machine that keeps
track of what instruction is being
executed but for PC there yeah yet
program counter what we've got we've got
the binary this is what's going on to
the computer itself but for us we've got
a little display here that allows us to
interpret that a little bit easier so we
can see that the instructions a memory
location is 131 to 137 are just going
round and round in a little bit so even
though the machine looked like it was
doing nothing it's running this little
program between 131 and 137 and what
that's saying is check out the
peripheral input the inputs here so
between 131 and 137 is just basically so
is that button pressed so it just sits
there in that loop if I speed up a
little bit and I now press that button
program counter now shoots off the
slowed it down again so now we're in a
different part of memory doing another
operation and you can see on the screen
so if I speed up the operations now you
can see that it's basically very very
slowly clearing the screen so the part
the program is operating the line issues
the
a screen operation and I could speed
that up take it up to the note playing
the game and now it's playing the game
again but again slowing it down you can
see just how long it takes to draw and
calculate those pieces so to update the
screen there is a whole load of code
that's being operated just to move that
piece down the screen and then we can
speed it up and now we have a kind of a
functional game it is going to slow
obviously it's not very playable and it
can look at the inputs and you can see
how controller here as we move it
changes the LEDs you've got the two
inputs there the button presses cause
other inputs and it is watching those
all the time
James Newman the madmen that created it
really wanted to be able to shrink
people down put the micellar computer
it's used to be able to see how it works
that's really hard
apparently so you scaled up the
processor so allowed us to get inside it
as it were so the idea is here that this
is an educational thing this is the best
way for anybody to understand things
simple stuff at the fetch and execute
cycle of a computer how does this stuff
work so this is fantastic because what
it allows us to do if we halt the
machine we can now stop the processor
and we can single step through every
instruction so every time we press the
step button we can now see the
operations and the data moving around
the system I'm just going to darken the
camera so we can see the LEDs now for
guru might not see you but yeah and it
is not necessarily one press per
instruction some of these instructions
take a number of clock cycles to operate
so a divide could take 16 clock cycle
cycles other instructions take best one
but we can see how that instruction is
broken up step it through just to see
how that data moves around the processor
you can't do that in any other way there
is no way to get inside a processor and
see this don't happen
I'd program the assembly language on 80
31 processors and things like that and I
thought I was fairly low level you know
programming at the metals they say but
actually when you see these things being
executed you realize how much extra
stuff is going on that even use it as
all the low-level coder
don't even you're not even aware of it
is
things work so hard to do that the what
seems simple stuff I'm analyzing you
mister the processor in some smartphones
and what other do you think the screen
would be um ah that's okay so that's an
interesting question if this was the
memory that you had in your mobile phone
today the average mobile phone with say
I don't know a gig of ram this panel as
the round would be twice the size of the
united kingdom so it's fairly low
density and fairly impractical but you
know you can't see what's going on in
your mobile phone so but actually what
we should say that a lot of people just
assume this is something like a model of
a 6502 or a z80 processor from the 80s
it's not actually necessarily based on
any one processor it kind of uses good
ideas from a number of different
processors so for a start it has
Hardware divided built in it's actually
a 16-bit machine as well so really it's
kind of a I don't know it's hard to
equate it but it's kind of a mid
nineties ish like early nineties it may
be kind of equivalent processor so it's
really quite a quite a beast when you
consider this thing is all just
transistors
[Music]
you